did you know that two out of every three
guys are going to experience some form
of male pattern boners by the time
they're 35. i know it i lost my hair
when i was about 25. but i wish keeps
have been around when i was younger
because advancements in science have
meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have
look it's too late for me my hair is not
coming back but you don't have to be
like me you could stop your hair loss
early thanks to keeps keeps off as
generic versions of the only two fda
approved drugs for treating hair loss so
you might have tried them before but
never at a price this low that's right
if you were thinking this is some sort
of medicine it's gonna be expensive you
couldn't be more wrong keep starts at
just ten dollars a month how does it
work well for one thing there's no need
to visit a doctor's office just schedule
a quick online consult a little bit
later a discreet package is going to
arrive at your door and you can use it
in the privacy of your own home so if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair that's one problem that's not going
to fix itself do something about it for
a limited time go to keeps.com forward
slash biographics or click the link in
the description below to receive 50 off
your first order and now today's video
depending on where your moral compass
points to you may consider today's
protagonist as a legend of colossal
proportions or as the ultimate scumbag
ordained po barely out of his teenage
years he went down in history as the
most outrageous of rome's bishops he
favored sword and armor to the mitre and
the cross he'd rather go hunting than
celebrate matt he led invasions plotted
against his friends and signed alliances
with his enemies he gambled he drank he
toasted the devil and performed gruesome
acts of violence with oblivious abandon
and all the while he gallivanted around
rome with the obstinate copulating
stamina of a duracell bunny and heat
fittingly this young pope went out with
a bang in more than one sense well at
least that's one version of events join
me today for the chronicle of what may
have been the most disastrous papacy in
history this is the story of octaviana's
son of alberic of the counts of tuscaloo
better known as pope john xii
let's start with some context in the
10th century 80 the italian peninsula
was kind of a mess and we know perfectly
well they're oversimplifying here so
please be merciful in the comments most
of the peninsula's northern half was
governed by the kingdom of italy the
style of the king of italy however was
little more than a nominal title as the
real military power lay in the hands of
powerful feudal lords still the italian
crown carried some prestige and
privileges kings of italy could aspire
to offer their protection to the pope
and in exchange expect to be crowned
holy roman emperors so let us now meet
the father of our protagonist he was one
of those feudal lords that we mentioned
his name was albrecht and his family
hailed from spelito a town 130
kilometers north of rome in 932 albert's
mother marozia married her third husband
the marquess hugh of province this
nobleman happened to also be the king of
italy as such he was expecting to be
crowned holy roman emperor 2. the
wedding took place in rome a city which
hugh sought to claim as his personal
dominion but his overambitious plans
were soon to be thwarted the local
aristocracy was not happy with the idea
of a foreign marquez lording it over
rome they started to conspire rallying
behind albrecht as their leader albrecht
was looking for the right occasion to
rebel against his stepdad the occasion
presented itself shortly after the
wedding morozia asked albright to pour
some water for hugh to wash his hands
alberich complied reluctantly which hugh
interpreted as a sign of disrespect he
slapped his stepson and the two got into
a fight days later albert got word that
he was planning to get back at him by
gouging his eyes this was the moment to
rebel the italian nobleman moved quickly
to the offensive he rallied the roman
aristocracy and the populace into an
uprising defeating you and driving him
away from the eternal city albrecht
became the de facto ruler of rome until
his death in august 954 before shuffling
off the mortal coil he forced the roman
nobles to take a pledge they would elect
his son octavianus as next pope and lord
of rome now we know very little about
the boy's early life or even the
circumstances around his birth according
to some sources octavianus was born in
937 to alberic and his wife alder who
happened to be his stepsister too this
was a confusing age according to others
the future pope had been born in 930 to
an unnamed concubine of alberix
octavianus became the 130th pope in
december of 955. depending on the origin
story he may have been 25 or barely 18.
in any case it probably was a tad too
early to take on such responsibilities
but the young pope accepted his destiny
choosing the name john xii as elected
pontiff and son of alberic he could
claim both spiritual authority over the
catholic church and temporal authority
over rome and the surrounding
ecclesiastical states
[Music]
from the very start of his reign
contemporary chronicles observed that
his character was unsuited to the task
john was impulsive coarse immoral and
more interested in earthly desires than
the christian faith as the energetic son
of a feudal lord he loved to hunt with
bow and arrow and he had several
mistresses and also a thirst for combat
john however was not just some medieval
chad looking for a random fight he did
have a clear agenda one already set in
motion by his dad alberic since the
times of charmaine popes had been
entitled to the patrimonium petri or the
patrimony of peter the term indicated
prize territories north and south of the
ecclesiastical states in the decades
after the death of the frankish emperor
though these lands had been seized by
other lords it was time to reconquer
those fiefdoms the young pope unsheathed
his sword and led his armies in what
should have been a glorious campaign but
no
it was a disaster john wanted too much
too soon to the north he attacked the
exarchate of ravina initiating a
conflict with the new king of italy
berengarius ii and his son adelbert at
the same time he took on the duchy of
capoeira south of rome he was quickly
defeated in both campaigns and suffered
a further humiliation when burningarius
marched on to pillage the ecclesiastical
states in 960. john needed allies and
quickly he knew that he would find no
love amongst italian lords even roman
aristocrats were turning against him
wary of his experience and lack of
morals in a true diplomatic move the
young pope sent two emissaries to the
court of otto the first the powerful
duke of saxony and king of east francia
the ambassadors proposed a military
alliance otto probably with the promise
of raising him to the rank of holy roman
emperor an author he simply could not
refuse moreover otto already had a beef
with beringarias do you remember hugh of
province the step-dad of albrecht the
king of italy would just lost rome after
slapping his stepson yeah that guy he
died in 947 the crown of italy had been
handed down to his son lotha lotha also
died shortly thereafter his widowed wife
adelaide was still crying over his body
when another feudal lord swept in and
seized the italian throne that lord was
burungarius until now a mere marquess
adelaide needed some help against the
usurper and so she appealed to otto
offering a hand in marriage so back in
951 otto had already organized an
expedition to italy to fulfill the
wishes of his new wife but he had to cut
short the invasion to deal with a revolt
in swabia and then to repel a hungarian
attack now otto had a fresh carcass
belly time to settle scores with those
who had wronged his lovely lady wife
[Music]
the german nobleman descended into italy
with a mighty army whose ranks were
swelled by the local lords who opposed
berengarius attacked from all sides the
king had to retreat to his fortress otto
continued his descent towards rome
sending an envoy to john xii in december
961. in his message otto pledged to
protect the person the life and the
honor of the pope with all his might he
also committed to restoring the
patrimony of peter and consult the pope
on any decision concerning the papacy in
the city of rome in his reply john
solemnly pledged friendship to otto he
also promised that he would never ally
himself with berengarius or his son
adelbert but apparently john did not
entirely trust the promises of the
german king having powerful protectors
is very useful provided they fornicate
off back to their country once the war
is over but what if they decided to
stick around what if they decide to turn
that pledge of protection
into a thirst for control that was
john's fear could the emperor be
planning to undermine papal authority
nonetheless john fulfilled his part of
the deal otto and adelaide reached rome
in january 962 and on the 2nd of
february they were crowned holy roman
emperor and impress immediately
afterwards john convened a councillor
bishops in which he sanctioned one of
otto's pet projects the foundation of an
archbishop in magdeburg was the aim of
evangelizing the slavic peoples surely
pleased by this concession the newly
crowned emperor issued the so-called
privilegium autonamium or ottonian
privilege with this document otto
confirmed his previous pledge of
restoring the patrimony then he
collected his army and marched back to
the north to resume his siege against
berungarius so everything appeared fine
and dandy for the pope right his new bff
had his back covered and he had decided
not to make himself cozy in rome but the
privilege contained a clause which john
didn't like one bit future popes were
required to pledge their obedience to
the emperor john may have been a serial
libertine but he was still the
representative of christ on earth surely
it should have been the other way around
emperors had to bow to popes in autumn
of 962 he organized a second council in
barbier northern italy in which he
yielded for the last time to otto's
requests namely reinstating some bishops
which had been expelled from their seats
but at the same time he was scheming
behind otto's back he negotiated a
secret alliance with his old enemies
berengaris and adulbert with the purpose
of booting the emperor out of the
italian boot news of the alliance leaked
otto the dumbfounded emperor could not
believe his ears and sent envoys to rome
to investigate one of them bishop
lutebrand of cremona confirmed the
rumors upon his return moreover the
bishop reported how the dissolute
lifestyle and poor administration of
john ii had left roman absolute shambles
while also processed the and john
doubled up he sent a team of bishops and
cardinals to the byzantine empire into
the kingdom of hungary seeking to create
a vast anti-imperial alliance
unfortunately for him two of them were
captured by his old enemy the duke of
kapoor the letters they carried were
solid proof of the pope's schemes if jon
had had his way otto would face defeat
in italy and an invasion in his homeland
the cat was now out of the bag and jon
tried to plaster over the whole mess he
hastily sent a message to otto claiming
that the letters seized in kapua were
just a forgery concocted to undermine
their friendship he took the occasion to
accuse the emperor of not fulfilling his
promise of restoring the patrimony you
see otto had reconquered some of the
lost lands of peter but had not returned
them to papal authority yet if anything
he was the traitor otto reacted
immediately by sending ludbran to rome
to refute these allegations luke brandt
even challenged john to solve their
quarrel with good old trial by combat as
much as we would have loved to see a
duel between a papal mountain an
imperial viper or vice versa john
rejected the idea and sent luke pran
packing shortly afterward adulbert
entered rome to formalize his alliance
with john well this was outrageous otto
now had no choice but take matters into
his own hands he regrouped his armies
and marched toward the eternal city in
november 963. john donned his armor and
rallied his troops ready to face the
emperor in a bloody siege but he had not
accounted for enemies within the city
walls more and more roman aristocrats
were sick and tired of the dissolute
pope and had no sympathy for adelbert
they organized revolt and defeated the
papal faction welcoming otto with open
arms john and adelbert had no choice but
to fly to nearby tiboli carrying a good
chunk of the church's treasure with them
the romans were not done with john
though on the 6th of november they
organized another council of bishops
with the purpose of trying the pope in
absentia
an old friend of luprand of cremona
penned an account of the trial which
gave us the full extent of the pope's
alleged crimes the pontiff came out with
a rap sheet as long as my arm he was
accused of celebrating mass without
receiving a communion first of not
respecting the canonical times for
prayer of ordaining a deacon at a
strange time of day while standing
inside a barn of appointing a
ten-year-old bishop and selling other
bishop bricks for money moreover jon had
committed sacrilege and perjury he
openly carried weapons and hunted with a
bow and arrow if that wasn't enough he
was indicted for adultery incest the
concoction of diabolical love potions
but there's still more the pope was
charged with grievous bodily harm and
murder apparently he had ordered his
godfather to be blinded and by the way
his godfather was a high-ranking cleric
a cardinal no less had been castrated
and then killed by papal goons lupren
also specified that john the 12th loved
to drink and to gamble toasting to satan
or invoking pagan deities before each
roll of the dice finally under his
administration churches have been left
in a state of abandon and disrepair the
papal residence the latter and palace
had been turned into a brothel oh and we
always forget he didn't do the sign of
the cross in his account luke brand of
cremona explicitly compared the pope to
judas and to the devil himself now such
a tsunami of allegations would have left
the whole borgia family seething with
envy had they been born some centuries
earlier but i should specify that
contemporary historians are a bit
skeptical about the extent of such
charges sure other sources confirm
john's licentiousness and disregard for
good admin practices but lupron's
writings should not be taken as gospel
after all he was a loyal servant to otto
and his record at the trial was probably
more of an exaggerated propagandistic
pamphlet than an honest transcript
unsurprisingly jon refuted all of the
allegations from his hiding place and
issued an excommunication for all
involved in the council nevertheless on
the 4th of december 963 the convened
bishops issued their verdict pressured
by otto john was to be deposed and a new
pope was to be elected the choice fell
upon the proto-grenarius leo leo however
piosonned about was not even a priest
let alone a bishop or a cardinal his job
description was superintendent of the
roman public schools for scribes a head
teacher in other words and he was
suddenly elevated to all the most
powerful positions in europe he was
crowned as leo the eighth on the 6th of
december
[Music]
the octavians formerly known as pope
john xii still had some metaphorical
arrows in his imaginary quiver from
tiboli he schemed to launch an
anti-imperial uprising in rome he still
had a few nobles loyal to him and he
gambled that the populace could be on
his side but how to set off the first
spark of the revolt according to the
ever-informed loot brand of cremona the
former pope used a network of reliable
agents his countless former lovers
finally some payback for all that
amorous effort on the 3rd of january 964
the supporters of octavianas took to the
streets actively looking to assassinate
otto and his pope leo but the emperor
and his faction was just too strong and
the revolt was quickly quashed but being
distracted by the riots utter had failed
to notice that adobe was on the
offensive once more he had rallied a new
army and set camp in spaletto north of
rome as otto marched north the
insurrection erupted again the imperial
garrison was repelled and leo viii fled
the city in february octavianus returned
to rome claiming back the papal throne
one of his first acts was to claim
vengeance on the bishops who had sided
with the emperor sources disagree on
which bishop received which punishment
but we can gather that a german bishop
was scourged a roman bishop had his nose
and ears cut off another bishop lost his
nose tongue and two fingers and a fourth
bishop had his right hand amputated then
on the 26th of february a further
council annulled the decisions taken by
the bishops the past november that is
leo's election was considered null and
void and obviously john was now cleared
of all charges the reinstated pope now
sat in wait of what was next otto's
inevitable reprisal he tried to appease
the emperor by releasing the bishop he
had flailed but if otto appeared to
postpone an attack it was due to
pragmatic logistical problems after
defeating burungarius and adelbert the
emperor needed reinforcements from
germany to replenish his losses when
otto finally planned to march on rome a
piece of news stopped him in his tracks
john xii died on the 14th of may 964 in
naples according to his harshest critic
bishop ludbrand the licentious young
pope had been hit by a stroke while
having sex with a married lady stricken
by paralysis john lay in bed for eight
days until the devil himself dealt a
blow to his temple according to another
version the pope was fit as a fiddle
while he frantically fornicated with his
friends the problem is her husband was a
bit fitter he burst into the room lifted
john by the neck and tossed him from a
window as i said out with a bang one way
or the other and thus ends the short and
scandalous life of one who may have been
the youngest and worst pope to ever be
elected the story of john the 12th and
his legacy are frequently resurrected by
contemporary commentators as an example
of how the spiritual mission of the
catholic church can be corrupted by
temporal power and hypocrisy as
mentioned earlier there is a strong
suspicion that most of the worst crimes
committed by john may have been
fabricated for propaganda purposes he
may have realistically indulged in the
sins of the flesh which was not uncommon
among popes and high-ranking prelates in
the middle ages but allegations of
murder devil worship and pimping should
be taken with many pinches of salt what
i would like to do is draw your
attention to his political legacy john's
scheming and military ambitions resulted
in the issuing of the ottoman privilege
a legal document which bound the
election and the autonomy of future
popes to the holy roman emperors
moreover as he tried to find a way out
he only succeeded in angering his once
allies thus setting a precedent for
recurring imperial interference in
italian affairs it took 14 popes and
almost one century before the ottoman
privilege was abolished by the church
which only resulted in further conflict
the so-called investiture controversy a
political religious and ideological
contest which degenerated into decades
of revolt and civil war in germany but
was stopped there before someone is
tempted to blame every european war on
john the 12th i'll leave the final
verdict up to you was he actually the
worst pope in history now just before
you leave today maybe look for something
else to watch why not check out my new
channel called wara graphics want to
know all of the details about some of
history's most famous battles and wars
come join me on wara graphics from
sherman's march to the sea to operation
barbarossa it's got people fighting each
other or occasionally animals we will
cover it there is a link below